AI doomers are driving me mad and AI the
fact that we don't have any intelligence
yet I call AI autonomous informatics
just to make people grumpy yeah um and
you're saying we're quite far away from
AGI I think that we have no conception
of intelligence and I think that we
don't understand how the human brain
does what it does I think that we are
neuroscienc is making great advances but
I think that we have no idea about AGI
so am a technological I guess Optimist I
believe we should do everything the
whole regulation of AI is nonsensical I
mean why would you regulate XL other
than the fact that clippy should come
back and I love XL 97 because we can
play um you know we can do the flight
flight simulator uh sorry in Excel yeah
have you not played the flight simulator
in Excel may7 yeah what does that look
like it's like wireframe very very basic
but basically I think it's x0 y0 shift
and it opens up and you can play the
fight simulator oh wow wait wait is he
using Excel Excel Excel 97 okay I
resurrected it the other day and saw
clippy again for the first time in a
long time well clippy is definitely
coming back but you're saying we don't
have a a great understanding of what is
intelligence what is the intelligence I
am very frustrated underpinning the
human mind I'm very frustrated by the
way that um we're AI dooming right now
now and people are bestowing some kind
of magic now um let's go back a bit so
you said about AGI are we far away from
AGI yes I do not think we're going to
get to AGI anytime soon I've seen no
evidence of it and the AI Doom scenario
is nonsensical in the extreme yeah um
and the reason why I think it's
nonsensical but it's not non
so I don't think there isn't things we
should do and be very worried about
right I mean there are things we need to
worry about right now what AI are doing
whether it's fake data fake users right
I want authentic people or authentic uh
um data I don't want everything to be
faked and I think it's a really big
problem and I'm absolutely want to go on
the record to say I really worry about
that what I'm not worried about is that
some fictitious entity is going to turn
us all to paper clips or detonate
nuclear bombs I don't
know maybe I don't know anything you
can't think of why is this is a and I'll
I'll take a very simple series of logic
arguments and and this is the the the AI
doomers are have not had the correct and
this is had not had the correct they do
not have the correct
epistemology they do not understand what
knowledge is and until we understand
what knowledge is they're not going to
get anywhere because they're applying
things falsely so let me give you a very
simple argument people talk about the
probability P Doom AI um I can we can
work out the probability of a asteroid
hitting the planet why because it's
happened before we know the mechanism we
know that there's a gravity well or that
you know SpaceTime is bent and stuff
Falls in we don't know the probability
of AGI because we have no mechanism so
let me give you the another one which is
like I'm really worried about AG what's
ag ag is anti-gravity one day we could
wake up and anti-gravity you know it's
discovered we're all going to die the
atmosphere is going to float away we're
going to float away we're all doomed
what is the probability of a AG we don't
know because there's no NE mechanism for
AG do we worry about it no and I don't
understand the current um reason for
these for the for certain people and
certain areas to be generating this
nonsense I think they're not doing it
maliciously I think we're observing the
emergence of new religions how religions
come because religions are about kind of
some control so you got The Optimist
saying AI is going to cure us all and a
I is going to kill us all what's the
reality well we don't have ai we have
really powerful machine learning tools
and they will allow us to do interesting
things and we need to be careful about
how we use those tools in terms of
manipulating human beings and faking
stuff right right uh well let me let me
try just sort of Steal man on the AI
dumers argument and actually I don't
know are AI dumers in the owski camp
saying it's definitely going to kill us
because there's a spectrum 95% I think
is the
95% plus that's no not not plus I think
I don't know I was seeing on Twitter
today various things but I think yski is
yski is at 95% but to belong to the AI
dumer Club is there a threshold I don't
know what the membership maybe and what
are the fees I think well I saw I think
Scott arenson like I was quite surprised
had put two I I saw this online so it
could be wrong so sorry if it's wrong um
says 2% but the thing is if you were to
go if you if someone said there's a 2%
chance you're going to die going into
the lift would you go into lift in the
elevator for the American English
speaking audience uh well no not for the
elevator so I would say anyone higher
than 2% I mean like I I mean I think
there's a z% chance of AGI Doom zero
just to push back on the on the
argument we're at n of zero on the AGI
we can see on Earth that there's
increasing levels of intelligence of
organisms we can see what humans with
extra intelligence were able to do to
the other species so
that is uh a lot of
samples of data what a delta in
intelligence gives you when you have an
increase in intelligence how you're able
to dominate a species on Earth and so
the idea there is that if you
have a a being that's 10x smarter than
humans we're not going to be able to
predict what that's going to mhm with
that being is going to be a able to do
especially if it has the power to hurt
humans which you can imagine a lot of
trajectories in which the more benefit
AI systems give the more control we give
to those AI systems over our power grid
over uh our nuclear weapons or weapons
of any sort and then it's hard to know
what a Ultra intelligence system would
be able to do in that case you don't
find that convincing I think this is I
would I would fail that argument 100%
here's a number of reason to fail it on
first of all um we don't know where the
intention comes from the problem is that
people think they keep you know watching
all the husters online with the prompt
engineering and all this stuff where
when I talk to a typical AI computer
scientist they keep talking about the AI
is having some kind of decision-making
ability that is a category
error the decision making ability comes
from human beings we have no
understanding of how humans make
decision we've just been discussing Free
Will for the last half an hour right we
don't even know what that is so the
intention I totally agree with you
people who intend to do bad things can
do bad things and we should not let that
risk go that's totally here and now I'm
do not want that to happen and I'm happy
to be regulated to make sure that
systems I generate whether they're like
computer systems or you know I'm working
on a new project called X called cam
mackina nice well done yeah yeah which
is basically
a um for people who don't understand the
point that xar is a great uh film about
I guess AGI embodied and chem as the
chemistry version of that and I only
know one way to embody intelligence
that's in chemistry and human brains so
category era number one is agency they
have agency category era number two is
saying that assuming that anything we
make is going to be more intelligent now
you didn't say super intelligent I'll
put the words into our mouths here super
intelligent that I think that um there
is
no no reason to expect that we are going
to make systems that are more
intelligent more capable you know when
people play chess computers they don't
expect to win now right they just the
chess computer is very good at chess
that doesn't mean it's super intelligent
so I think that super intelligence I
mean I think even Nick Bostrom is is
pulling back on this now because he this
so I see this a lot when did see first
happen Eric Drexler nanot technology
atomically precise ma machines he came
up with a world where we had these atom
cogs everywhere they were going to we're
going to make self replicating Nanobots
not possible why because there's no
resources to build these self-replicate
Nanobots you can't get the Precision it
doesn't work it was a major category
error in Def taking engineering
principles down to the molecular level
the only functioning molecular
technology we know sorry the only fun F
nanomolecular technology we know
produced by Evolution there so now let's
go forward to AGI what is Agi we don't
know it's super it can do this or can
humans can't think that I would argue
the only agis that exist in the universe
produced by Evolution and sure we may be
to make our working memory better we
might be be able to do more things the
human brain is the most compact
Computing unit in the universe uses 20
watts it's uses a read Limited volume
it's not like a chat GPT cluster which
has to have thousands of Watts model
that's generated and has to be corrected
by human beings you are autonomous and
embodied intelligence so I think that
there are so many levels that we're
missing out we've just kind of went oh
we've discovered fire oh gosh the
planet's just going to burn one day
randomly I mean I just don't understand
that leap there are bigger problems we
need to worry about so what is the
motivation why are these people let's
just assume they have their Earnest have
this conviction well I think it's just
it's kind of they're making leaps that
they're trapped in a virtual reality
that isn't reality well I mean I can
continue a set of arguments here but
also it is true that
ideologies that fear Monger are
dangerous because you can then use it to
control to to regulate in a way that uh
halts progress
to control people and to uh to cancel
people all that kind of stuff so you
have to be careful because you reason
ultimately wins right but there there is
a lot of concerns with super intelligent
systems very capable systems when you I
think when I when you hear the word
super intelligent you're hearing like
it's smarter than humans in every way
that humans are smart but
the paperclip manufacturer ing system
doesn't need to be smart in every way
just need to be smart in a set of
specific ways and the more uh capable
the a systems become the more you could
see us giving them control over like I
said our power grid a lot of aspects of
human life and that means they will be
able to do more and more damage when
there's unintended consequences that
come to life I I think that that's right
that the unintended consequences we have
to think about and I'm that I fully I
fully agree with but let's go back a bit
sentient I mean I'm again I'm far away
from my comfort zone and all this stuff
but hey let's talk about it cuz I give
myself a qualification yeah we're both
qualified in sentients I think yeah as
much as anyone else I think the
paperclip scenario is a just such a poor
one because let's think about how that
would happen um and also let's think
about we are being so um unrealistic
about how much of the Earth's surface we
have commandeered MH you know for permit
clip manufacturing to really happen I
mean do the math it's like it's it's not
going to happen there's not enough
energy there's not enough resource where
they all going to come from I think that
what happens in evolution is really it
why is why is a killer virus not killed
out all of not killed all life on Earth
what happens is sure super killer
viruses that kill the ribosome have
emerged but you know what happens they
nuke a small space because they can't
propagate they all die so there's this
interplay between Evolution and
propagation right and death and so in
evolution you don't think it's possible
to engineer for example sorry to
interrupt but like a perfect virus no
that's deadly enough no nonsensical okay
I think that just wouldn't again it
wouldn't work it was too deadly it would
just kill the radius and not replicate
it yeah I mean but you don't think it's
possible to get a I mean if you were
super I mean I if you
were it not kill all of life on Earth
but kill all humans there's not many
many of us there's only like 8
billion there there's so much more ants
I mean I don't I so many more
ants and they're pretty smart I think we
the nice thing about what we where we
are I would love for the AI crowd to
take a leaf out of the book of the
biowarfare chemical warfare
crowd um I mean not love cuz actually
people have been killed with chemical
weapons in the first and second world
war and people and bioweapons have been
made and you know we can argue about
covid-19 and all this stuff let's not go
there just now but I think there is a
consensus that some certain things are
bad and we shouldn't do them right and
um and sure it would be possible for a
bad actor to to engineer something bad
but the LI the damage would be we would
see it coming and we would be able to do
something about
it um
now I I I guess what I'm trying to say
is when people talk about doom and they
just when you ask them for the mechanism
they just say um you know they just make
something up I'm I mean in this case I'm
with Yan Lon I think you put out a very
good point about trying to regulate jet
engines before we've even vented them
yeah and I think that's what I'm saying
I'm not saying we should I just don't
understand why these guys are going
around making literally making stuff up
about us all dying yeah when basically
we need to actually really focus on now
let's say there's some as Earnest right
let's say owski is Being Earnest right
and he really cares but but he loves it
goes and then you're all going to die
it's like you know why don't we try and
do the same thing and say you could do
this and then you're going to be happy
forever after yeah you know well I I
think uh there's several things to say
there uh one I think there is a role in
society for people that say we're all
going to die because I
think uh it filters through as a message
as a viral message that gives us the
proper amount of uh concern
conern meaning not the it's not 95% but
when you say 95% and it filters through
Society you'll give an average of like a
0.3% an average so it's nice to have
people that are like we're all going to
die then we'll have a proper concern
like for example I do believe we're not
properly concerned about the threat of
nuclear weapons currently like that that
it just seems like people have forgotten
that that's a thing and you know there's
a war in Ukraine with the nuclear power
involved there's nuclear Powers
throughout the world and it just feels
like we're on the brink of a potential
World War to a percentage that I don't
think people are properly calibrating
like in their head we're all thinking
it's a Twitter battle as opposed to like
actual threat so like it's nice to have
that kind of level of concern but to me
like what I when I hear AI doomers what
I'm imagining is with unintended
consequences a potential situation
where uh let's say 5% of the world
suffers deeply because of a mistake made
of unintended consequences I don't
imagine the entirety of human
civilization dying but there's could be
a lot of suffering if this is done I I
understand that and I'm I kind of I
guess I mean I'm involved in the whole
hype cycle like why what I would like us
to I don't want us to so what's
happening right now is there seems to be
so let me let's say having some people
saying ai ai Doom is a worry fine let's
give them that but it what seems to be
happening is there seems to be people
who don't think AI is doing they're
trying to use that to control regulation
and to push people into regulate where
which which stops humans generating
knowledge and I am an advocate for
generating as much knowledge as possible
when it comes to nuclear weapons I grew
up in the 70s and ' 80s where the
nuclear Doom a lot of adults were really
had existential threat almost as bad as
now with AI Doom they were really
worried right there was some great well
not great there was some hor horrific
documentaries I think there's one called
Freds that was generated in the UK which
was like it was terrible it was like so
scary um and I think that the correct
thing to do is obviously get rid of
nuclear weapons but let's think about
unintended consequences we've got rid of
is such a non secr we got rid of all the
SU particles in the atmosphere right or
the all the s and what's happened in the
last couple years is global warming has
accelerated because we've cleaned up the
atmosphere too
much so sure I mean the same thing if
you get rid of nuclear weapons you're
going exactly that's my point is if so
what we could do is if we actually
started to put the AI in charge which is
I really like an AI to be in charge of
all World politics and this is sounds
ridiculous for a second hang on but if
we could all agree on the the aumers
just woke up yeah yeah yeah on that
statement but I really don't like
politicians who are basically just
looking at local sampling but if you
could say globally look here's some Game
Theory here there how what is the
minimum number of nuclear weapons we
need to distribute around the N the
world to everybody to basically reduce
War to zero I mean just the Start
experiment of the United States and
China and Russia and major nuclear
Powers get together and say all right
we're going to distribute nuclear
weapons every single nation on Earth
y oh boy I mean that has a probably
greater than 50% chance of eliminating
major military conflict yeah yeah but
it's not 100% but it but I don't think
anyone will use them because I think I
think and look what you've got to try
and do is like for to qualify for these
nuclear weapons I this is a great idea
the game theorist could do this right I
think the question is this I I really by
your question we have too many nukes um
from just from a feeling point of view
that we've got too many of them so let's
reduce the number but not get rid of
them because we'll have too much
conventional Warfare so then what is the
minimum number of nuclear weapons we can
just shot around to to remove what hum
humans hurting each other is something
we should stop doing it's in it's not
out with our our conceptual capability
but right now what about the Nations
certain Nations that are being um
exploited for their natural resources
and the future because for a short-term
gain because we don't want to generate
knowledge and and so if everybody had an
equal doomsday
switch I I predict the quality of life
average human will go up faster I am an
optimist and I believe that humanity is
going to get better and better and
better that we're going to eliminate
more problems um but I think yeah let's
but uh the probability of a bad
actor of one of the Nations setting off
a nuclear
weapon
I mean you have to you have to integrate
that into the but we we get we
distribute the N nukes like population
right we give what we do is we can't
believe but anyway let's let's just go
there they say so if a if a small nation
with a couple of nukes uses one because
they're a bit bored or annoyed they're
going to they the likelihood that they
are going to be pummeled out of
existence immediately is 100% MH and yet
they've only they've only nuked one
other city I know this is crazy and I
apologize for well no no I think this
just to be clear we're just having a
thought experiment that's interesting
but you know there's terrorist
organizations that would take that would
take would take that trade yeah I mean
we have to ask ourselves a question of
how many Which percentage of humans
would be suicide bombers essentially
where where they would sacrifice their
own life to to uh because they hate
another group of people and that I
believe it's a very small fraction but
is it large enough enough to uh if you
give out nuclear weapons I can predict a
future where we take all nuclear
material and we burn it for energy right
as because we're getting there and the
other thing you could do is say look
there's a gap so if we get all the
countries to sign up to the virtual
nuclear agreement where we all exist we
have a simulation where we can nuke each
other in the simulation and the and the
economic consequences are
catastrophic sure in the simulation I
love it it's not going to kill all
humans is just going to have economic
consequen I don't know I just made it up
it seems like I mean it's but it's
interesting whether that would have as
much power on human psychology as actual
physical nuclear think so it's possible
but people don't take Economic
Consequences as seriously I think as
actual nuclear weapons I think they do
in Argentina and they do in Somalia and
they do in a lot of these places where
no I I think this is a great idea I'm a
strong Advocate now for so what have we
come up with burning burning all the
nuclear material to have energy and
before we do that to because mad is good
mutually assured destruction is very
powerful let's take it into the
metaverse and then get people to kind of
um uh subscribe to that and if they
actually nuke each other even for fun in
the metaverse there are dire
consequences yeah yeah so it's like a
video game we all have to join this
metaverse video game yeah I can't dire
Economic Consequences I don't know how
and uh it's all run by AI as you
mentioned which so the AI doomers is are
really terrified at this point
no they're happy they have a job for
another 20 years right oh you're hry
yeah yeah yeah we got I'm a Believer in
equal
employment